well I did want to reflect a little bit
on how we feel oh now that we know that
the boys are gone yeah the episode came
out yeah
and then we said what we said we said
what we said we made fun of that control
and half of the comments were like
we're like because I feel like this was
the General sentiment is that like half
the people about talking about the
submarine were memeing on it yeah and
then the other half of the people were
like how dare you meme on this five
people are potentially suffering in like
a little jail cell at the bottom of the
ocean turns out you were wrong turns out
they suffered zero yeah exactly turns
out they actually didn't know they died
which is pretty wild that that statistic
yeah is the one that's been messing with
me the most what
the like the implosion took half a
millisecond and it takes your brain
whatever a quarter of a millisecond to
process something so if you if you don't
know you died are you still alive
well no no think about that first sir
okay I'll think
no
it's almost it's almost like it took you
longer than half a millisecond yeah
process that yeah
that's a really wild thing to just just
not even
like they're all like
how can they can I see the Titanic
all right now that that's getting in the
territory what what
cause okay
the guy released the sandbags and the
other stuff like he knew something was
up oh did he yeah yeah that's what the
logically he must have known something
so it was probably
inform me on this because I didn't know
any of this so he the they found two
elements from the sub
that it was like a set of sandbags and
then there was uh something beneath
that's like attached to the bottom of
the sub that really so he was releasing
things to try to get it to surface
that's oh I didn't know that so he
it was probably a situation where he
went
um okay I'm just gonna go ahead and
release this uh see there's an issue we
need to go back to the
sorry
I see it's not fair because the
Situation's serious
with the way it happens is not
it's like it's right
it is it is sad and it's a shame that
five people's lives were lost
but at the same
no it what no it is
that's bad that's bad
I wasn't doing that to be funny I'm just
saying like that's procedurally what
probably happened right you know what
do it again
I can't but it is it is very fortunate
yeah they just suffer didn't suffer yeah
yeah but maybe they were like a little
panicked for a second which is kind of
sad maybe they but to what degree
because with that guy's confidence he
probably didn't think anything was wrong
you know what's crazy is
um I sent this I don't think I sent in
the slack but there's a did you see the
YouTube channel it's like this the guy
that's a diver this is a a 26 minute
video where he's like I was on the
mission before this the one that
than imploded and they did the whole
prep everything like they got fitted for
you know I it's like a it's like a major
major thing there's like tens of
I don't know like there's like 20 or 30
people working on this mission right on
this ship getting everything prepped
making sure everything's good yeah and
then it got canceled because of fog or
something like that but they would have
been the one probably oh my God
oh my God but I think what's
what is kind of interesting about this
video is that like it shows that it's
like a way more serious process than
everyone was kind of making it seem yeah
you know like we the videos that we
watched and everything it's like oh this
thing's [__] janky but it's like
there's tons of people working on this
yeah and they were taking a lot of
precautions I think we were saying just
given some of the people going down
you'd be comfortable you'd go oh well
they've done it I probably you know yeah
even on that alone I think we were
definitely saying
you could be convinced to ride this
thing down the CEO had it in his mind
that
he knew the amount of Dives they could
do while
cat like he felt that he could calculate
the risk
so he in his mind he knew the hall was
compromised because there were cracks
showing in the carbon fiber and his mind
he felt oh uh we have this many left
he felt confident enough to say oh we
could do oh we got like three Dives left
before the hole goes
and which is insane yeah yeah and I
guess he's gone on record to say things
like
safety is stupid and
you know which he was clearly wrong
about that
yeah but yeah
yeah and and so I guess he had done
Dives previous and while they were going
he had told people in the hall hey don't
freak out you're gonna hear some cracks
and it was the it was the things
yeah that's horrible yeah
so it was janky yeah oh it was
indefinitely Jake yeah all the you know
a bunch of random people on Tick Tock
now that understand just you know
material composition and stuff they've
all this one I saw one where this person
said if I knew that it was made of
carbon fiber the second I heard that I
always said no thank you yeah you know
what's funny about these two is that I
saw his girlfriend's Tick Tock about
this and then I watched this video and
the whole thing is just kind of weird
tone because it's like he's sort of like
this is the footage of me doing this and
he's sort of reflecting on like what if
this was me sort of and then the pinned
comment
it's him being like not that it matters
not that it matters right because it's a
real tragedy what happened here but like
I just want to let everyone know I
didn't pay for my ticket
it was it was comped she want to let
everyone know
s like people were just roasting in the
comments for
spending 200k on this thing and he was
like I didn't dude that's like
that's all it's not the same it's almost
like getting in a car accident and then
being embarrassed of people finding out
what you drive yeah like it was a rental
I wouldn't pay for a Kia Sorento yeah
exactly come on not that it matters not
that it matters but
you know yeah or it's like yeah get in
an accident no no it was found out that
you rode in an Uber previous to a
horrific accident yeah exactly you're
like I would
I normally order you know yeah wait wait
you were my Uber you were in an Uber
pool it was comps
yeah I got a gift card I would never
choose I got a I got a promo code for a
party and it just turns out it almost
only worked with uberpool so like I
don't normally take uberpool not that
that matters does any still of a thing
even uberpool yeah yeah is it yeah I
know that no it's weird they
they bring an above ground pool to your
place
foreign